hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to have a
quick lesson on hydration
shells so let's go ahead and get started
with hydration shells i want you to
understand that we're talking about a
solution
and remember that a solution is where
you have a solute that is dissolved
in a solvent
so the solute is dissolved in the
solvent and that makes a solution
when we're talking about cases where the
solvent
is water then we call this an aqueous
solution
so i'll write that right here if it's
water
it's an aqueous solution
so that brings us to hydration shells
when an ionic compound remember
ionic is talking about when you have a
positively charged atom
and a negatively charged atom and they
those positive and negative charges
are attracted to each other and that
forms a an ionic
bond uh and so the an electron is
transferred there you have an electron
that's lost from one atom and gained by
another atom that creates the positive
and the negative
and then they have that ionic bond when
you have
a some kind of ionic compound something
like sodium chloride or
potassium fluoride or magnesium chloride
or magnesium bromide or
calcium chloride there's a whole bunch
of different ones when they are
dissolved
in water each of those ions
is surrounded by a sphere of water
molecules
and this is called a hydration gel
and so what does this look like i'm
going to draw an example
for ionic compounds with this one i'm
going to use
just the basic example of sodium
chloride so you put sodium chloride
into water and it dissolves
how does it do that well it's because of
these hydration shells
so first you have the sodium chloride
dissociate
or ionize that means that
it forms its ions so a positively
charged
sodium ion and a negatively charged
chloride ion now what happens with
the water i'm actually going to grab
another marker real quick
i think it'll be easier to see okay
so with the water remember that water
itself
has a separation of charges it's made up
of
two polar covalent bonds and the
electrons
in those covalent bonds are shared
unequally
and this means that the oxygen of water
has a partial negative charge and the
hydrogens of water have a partial
positive charge
so i'm going to draw that here i'm going
to draw
a water molecule with its partially
negative charged oxygen
forming an interaction with this
positively charged sodium
and now i'm just going to
draw a few more of these
here we go so here we have
all these water molecules that have
their partially negatively charged
oxygens
oriented toward or facing the sodium ion
so that you get all of these regions of
partial negative charge
on those oxygens interacting with the
positive charge on the sodium ion
with the chloride ion it's very similar
except remember that the chloride ion is
not positively charged is negatively
charged
and so what part of the water molecule
do you think is going to
orient towards that negatively charged
chloride ion
well if you guessed hydrogen you're
correct let me draw
what one of these looks like here's a
water molecule
remember that it is the hydrogens that
are partially positive
so they will have an interaction with
the negative
chloride ion so i'm going to
draw a few more of these
so in all of these cases you've got the
partially positive
hydrogen oriented
towards the negative chloride ion and so
these
structures right here are the hydration
shells
so this right here is a hydration shell
this right here is a hydration shell
and in both cases you just have water
using
the partial charges that it has either
the partial negative on the oxygen or
the partial positive on the hydrogens
to interact with these ions
in such a way that allows them to be
dissolved
in that water solvent so these are
the traditional hydration shells now i
want to
point out how things look with polar
molecules
they're not hydration shells in the
sense that we see right here
but we still see interactions with water
and polar molecules that help them to be
soluble help them to dissolve in water
so an example of this would be something
like an alcohol so for example
i'm just going to draw methanol so
methanol looks like this we've got a ch3
attached to an oxygen attached to a
hydrogen
and it's this right here
that makes this an alcohol
that oh group right there
and so right here we still have polar
covalent bonds
we still have a
partially positive hydrogen and a
partially
negative oxygen and so when you drop
something like methanol into water
the water can form
these same types of interactions and i
should say these are called hydrogen
bonds when you've got
bonds between um between a hydrogen
and either an oxygen fluorine or
nitrogen so right here i'm going to draw
some of these hydrogen bonds here is
one water molecule
we've got it's partial negative and it's
going to be attracted to the partial
positive of this hydrogen
i can draw with our
we're going to we're going to reverse it
again just like we saw here where the
different side of the water molecule
oriented towards either a positive or
negative
we'll see that here we've got the
partial negative on this oxygen oriented
towards the hydrogen
and now we'll have kind of the opposite
example where we have
the partial positive of this hydrogen
forming a hydrogen bond right here so i
should say i want to make it clear these
right here are not
um hydrogen bonds and then in the proper
sense because a hydrogen bond is a bond
between
a hydrogen and then either a fluorine
oxygen or nitrogen on another
uh compound which is not what's
happening here but it is what's
happening here
so these right here would be hydrogen
bonds you've got the
these um intermolecular forces meaning
they're between two different molecules
so between the alcohol and water
and it's all rooted in this partial
positive on the hydrogen partial
negative on the oxygen
and how those are attracted to each
other and so this right here is also
why polar molecules um you might have
heard these called hydrophilic
molecules remember hydrophilic means
water loving why these things can
dissolve in water it all has to do with
these types of interactions
that are rooted in water having these
partial positives and partial negatives
and so that's it for today if you're
interested in watching another video i
have one that is called
um how does water hydrogen bond and it
goes into
this in a lot more detail particularly
with with um
oxidant electronegativity and the
unequal sharing of electrons and just
exactly how that happens
in actuality so check out that video and
thanks for watching today bye